we begin in afghanistan where fighting
is escalating between the taliban and
the resistance group in the panguir
valley the mountainous enclave is about
150 kilometers north of the capital
kabul it's been the only province to
hold out against taliban rule despite
being entirely surrounded
charles stratford reports from gulbahar
the gateway to that region
smoke rises over the town of gulbahar
the entrance to the panshir valley in
northeast afghanistan
neither the soviets during the 1980s war
nor the taliban have ever managed to
control this mountainous region around
100 kilometers north of kabul
a shell lands nearby
taliban fighters ready their weapons
men in this village say they have driven
their wives and children to safety they
are angry and scared
the americans betrayed us president
ghani betrayed us too
you left us under the cannons and tanks
and we can't stop either side fighting
how much can they kill their brothers
how much can they kill their fellow
afghans
they have to stop fighting
the taliban drive american military
vehicles and pick up trucks taking
fighters to and from the front line
thousands of men like these across
afghanistan have known little else but
conflict and war all their lives
the fighting started three days ago now
we've taken a lot of areas up there by
the antenna we have no issue with the
civilians we are here to defend their
rights people are staying in their homes
the national resistance front of
afghanistan or nrf is believed to be
several thousand strong and made up of
mainly ethnic tajik fighters and former
afghan army soldiers the group is led by
this man ahmad masood
he's british military academy trained
and the son of ahmad shah masoud who
fought against the soviets and the
taliban was assassinated by al-qaeda two
days before the 9 11 attacks in 2001
ahmad massoud is demanding the taliban
form an inclusive government which
guarantees the rights of all
afghanistan's ethnic minorities
including ethnic tagics who make up
around a quarter of the country's
population
the fighting started after two weeks of
negotiations with the taliban collapsed
we have a lot of equipment with
ourselves we will defend from our willy
from our territory until we have one
blood of one drop of blood in our body
so we will resist until we martial in
here
taliban fighters edge up a slope along
tracks they say are heavily mined
as we were getting ready to go live
another shell landed close by
the taliban has blocked phone networks
in the valley there are growing fears
about the estimated
000 people living inside and many in
taliban controlled areas around gulbahar
the big concern is that massoud's forces
are coming round on the mountain ridges
trying to surround this area in order to
isolate gulbahar
we left in gulbahar but now we are
living
today i came from kabul to collect our
belongings
i already took my family out the
fighting is ongoing there are shells
hitting people's homes both sides are
shelling
afghan families flee for their lives in
one of the last pockets of resistance to
taliban rule
al jazeera near gulbahar afghanistan